unbelievable stop not once but twice the
second one of Beauty with the right pad
extend he's it over to tanet tanet shoots turned
away by nool rebound to the creas knocked Away
by the defenseman that was Dale bailing on his
goer big Save By doall The Rebound was in behind
him dryel knocked it away what a stop and Jamie
dryel comes in and twice prevents that puck from
going over the line hurdle circles up high through
the slot back door and held out by ridic Ferraro
Came Crashing Down andic keeps this scoreless
here in the first to the near side Jus into it
across s gorv s gorv and he's on top of the puck
unbelievable from Alexander gorv and gorv gets
it over and stops not one but two shots before
he covers that puck that is something you can
build off MO Baldi centers ericon a then capriso
had a p save byar the rebound of Middleton Omar
unbelievable stop not once but twice the second
one of Beauty with the right pad extent strome
closing oetkin slap pass down low incredible
save by Ms leakin gymnastic ability in the
net and doing the splits to make the stop
is M lein Elvis M leans with another solid
stop Markin holds a pass in Fr hard with a
spectacular save on Go's bear as the hord sounds
ending over time oh my oh my that is quite a read
by heart I mean you you don't have many bodies to
worry about on three on three like that basically
just a redirect and then in the overtime just
spectacular saucers to paner down low krider
back door save made by skner he Robs a Skinner
stops it with his blocker as he gets across to
make a remarkable save good save by Skinner in
a good second effort here by Darnell nurse
to stay in the hunt for this Puck down low
forehand save M by quick he robbed Heyman right
on the edge of the crease now Heyman makes his
living in that three feet right in front of
the blue paint he made a nice move and quick
beat him too McDavid in the slot save made by
quick sprawling to Rob tridal and tro clears
this is Stanley Cup Jonathan Quick brilliant
performance here in the second period Jared
Tori gloves it down a two on0 inside One Stop
rebound try faili in and out and stay up behind
Primo unbelievable that was stro behind Primo
in the second one save Primo rebound boiler
and from from his own net struble kept it out
the Montreal defenseman like a second goalie
oh my goodness he thought it was in the net
but Billy had his arms up Carlson toar Zeller
shooting that Miss Carter side of the n and
forsberg got across to make the save dve it
off for Carlson Carlson to malan Fires for for the
Stop Carter trying to get through oh what a save
by fors Canan Rael with a blocker take another
look at a couple of those Saves by Anton for B
the first one you actually were hoping that
a little more heat was coming off that back
wall unable to get that first one Carter kind of
kicks it over and Anton forsberg just robs the
Penguins here's a chance for geeky in alone LFC
by flurry here's a breakway this is not exactly
the first shot you'd like to see as a breakaway
from the blue line but Mark Andre flurry does not
bite on the fake shot into the middle now here's
Wilson with a shot rebound Sav by vasileski it was
Wilson who took the initial shot and vasileski
forced to make two saves in succession there
Wilson shot off the toe and you see oie slide
it back underneath them works it low B from Le
bank that one got Ricochet in toward the goal
line Anderson went diving and held out by the
king and look how close that was as Anderson gets
his hand in there as well as he reaches back for
that right hand you'll watch Mikey Anderson
here as it almost deflects off his skating
in second period panan with a shot rebound and
Lucan and just got over in the nick of time who
it looked like he was not going to get there
but he did yeah he makes a big save here but
he's able to recover you see that right pad coming
across right here he does a nice job making that
save